[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans
Parlement Hebdo retour en 26 minutes sur
les événements qui ont marqué
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat cette
semaine et nous accueillons cette
semaine Hervé Marseille bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur des hautes scèes
président du groupe de l'Union centriste
au Sénat et également vice-président du
groupe d'amitié France Israël à la Haute
Assemblée Hervé Marseille on reviendra
bien évidemment avec vous sur la
situation au Proche Orient Emmanuel
Macron s'est exprimé ce jeudi dans une
allocution solennelle il a promis de
tout faire pour sauver les otages
français en appelant à l'unité nationale
et nous reverrons les hommages et les
réactions politiques nombreuses à
l'assemblé au Sénat une semaine après
ces attaques terroristes du Hamas contre
Israël qui bouleverseent la
géopolitique on parlera également du
budget 2024 que les députés ont commencé
à examiner et qui met fin notamment au
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie sous
pression l'exécutif se prépare à
utiliser l'article 493 le chef de l'État
a donc pris la parole jeudi dans une
allocution télévisée sur cette guerre au
proche- Orient Emmanuel Macron a essayé
de rassurer nos concitoyens sur le sort
des otages français détenus par le Hamas
comme nous nous inquiétons pour le sort
de nos 17 compatriotes enfants et
adultes portés disparu et sans doute
pour certains d'entre eux retenus en
otage je pense ce soir aux familles je
veux leur dire que la France met tout en
œuvre au côté des autorités israéliennes
et avec nos partenaires pour les faire
revenir sain et sauf dans leur foyer car
jamais la France n'abandonne ses enfants
Hervé Marseille première réaction sur ce
qu'a dit jeudi le président de la
République qu'est-ce que peut faire la
France pour nos otages français détenus
par le Hamas est-ce qu'on doit d'une
certaine manière négocier avec cette
organisation via des pays intermédiaires
écoutez euh moi j'étais à l'Élysée hier
avec les responsables des des partis
politiques et donc à l'évidence une des
priorités que nous a annoncé le chef de
l'État c'était d'obtenir la libération
de nos otages il y a une vingtaine de
français dont on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
sont devenus alors peut-être certains
malheureusement sont morts mais d'autres
peuvent être a Tage dont des enfants et
c'est une priorité pour la France après
on sait très bien qu'on ne négocie
jamais en direct il y a toujours des
médiations et tout tout ça est du
domaine de la discrétion et du secret
donc on n sait pas plus mais on peut
imaginer qu'il y a des pays de la région
on pense à l'Égypte au Qatar ou à
d'autres qui sont des intermédiaires
pour essayer de d'obtenir la libération
de nos otages alors le président de la
République lors de son discours de son
allocution a appelé longuement à l'unité
du pays on voit en France une hausse des
attaques antisémites est-ce que vous
craignez que ce conflit ne s'importe en
France malheureus ement c'est on peut le
redouter mais tout doit être fait pour
éviter justement cette fracture
supplémentaire au sein de de notre pays
euh c'est vrai qu'il y a une montée de
la haine il suffit de regarder les
réseaux sociaux on voit immédiatement
qu'il y a une une montée des invectives
et et et des horreurs qui sont
proférées on nous a
dit le chef de l'État nous a dit queil y
avait eu environ 140 fait judiciarisé
euh et caractérisé comme des actes
d'antisémitisme on voit bien qu'il y a
une montée comme toujours dans ces
moments de tension donc il faut tout
faire
pour faire en sorte que que que le le
conflit ne s'importe pas chez nous on a
vu c'est récemment encore un tas de
manifestations euh so il faut interdire
ces manifestations proalestines bah
c'estàd raison de voir les interdire
benah oui parce que ça commence par
message pour la paix ça finit par Israël
assassin donc à un moment donné on peut
pas justifier par des de soi-disant
manifestations pacifiques des actes de
violence donc c'est à la justice le cas
échéant d'intervenir alors RV Marseille
toute la semaine les hommages et les
réactions politiques se sont succédés
après cette attaque sans précédent du
Hamas au Sénat la droite demande la
qualification de crime contre l'humanité
tandis qu'à l'Assemblée nationale la
réaction ambigue de la France insoumise
suscite beaucoup de critiques
horreur
sidération des mot fort et l'émotion
dans la voix de Bron PIV mi les députés
ont rendu hommage au victimes des
massacres en
Israël le recueil de l'Assemblée mardi a
laissé place à celui du Sénat mercredi
je vous
invite à vous lever pour observer une
minute de vousez un moment solennel sous
les yeux de l'ambassadeur d'Israël en
France puis d'autres mot forts on
raésonn Palais du Luxembourg ce de
Gérard larch les Mac commis dans les Kib
de
Berry un nom des crimes contre
l'humanité crime contre l'humanité les
sénateurs souhaitent déposer une
résolution pour qualifier les faits
crime contre l'humanité c'est la réalité
ce mot cette expression utilisezla
faites-la utiliser par l'Europe
franchement vu ce qui s'est passé crime
contre l'humanité c'est bien le
minimum mais Roger karucci demande plus
au gouvernement il l'appelle aussi à
condamner ceux qui ne soutiennent pas
Israël en ligne de mire la France
insoumise mardi en conférence de presse
Mathilde Panau refuse de qualifier le
Hamas d'organisation
terroriste nous ne changerons pas d'un
yota notre position qui est celle des
partisans de la la
paix et nous n'accepterons pas je le
redis encore une fois qu'on nous prête
des mots qui ne sont pas les ntres dans
l'émicycle elle est huée par les LR et
quelques députés de la majorité il
quitent leur siège le temps de son
intervention LFI est ensuite pointé du
doigt par l'ensemble des partis dans les
deux assemblées absolument rien et je
dis vraiment absolument rien ne justifie
le terrorisme ceux qui soutiennent
l'insoutenable l'excuse ou le relativise
et dont certains siègent sur ban attente
aux valeurs humaines le ramas est bien
une organisation terroriste ne pas
clairement le reconnaître sous couvert
d'explications vaseuses relève de
l'indignité un comportement également
dénoncé par le gouvernement Elisabeth
borne refuse dit-elle toute
ambigué ma conviction c'est que face au
drames terribles qui frappe
Israël notre devoir c'est de veiller à
l'unité nationale à la cohésion
nationale la première ministre a
également évoqué les familles de
victimes et disparu français Emmanuel
Macron confirme que plusieurs enfants
figurent parmi les otages VO alors la
droite demande donc au Sénat le la
qualification de crime contre l'humanité
en droit international c'est c'est très
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'incrimination
qui a été créée en 1945 dans le statut
du tribunal de de Nuremberg est-ce qu'il
faut qualifier ces faits de crime contre
l'humanité ce que ne fait pas ce que n'a
pas encore fait la France oui euh à
l'évidence il faut le faire je l'ai
évoqué hier jeudiis ce jeudi je ce jeudi
devant le chef de l'État et
euh à l'évidence c'est un sujet qui dont
il va falloir s'emparer il y a des
urgences il y a le deuil il y a la
guerre parce que c'est une guerre et
viendra le moment où il faudra traiter
ces dossiers il faut les éta il y a des
enqu long oui il y a des enquêtes en
cours la réponse est claire il faut que
nous portions devant le le tribunal
international cette définition de crime
contre l'humanité qui s pass pourquoi le
chef de l'État ne le fait pas pourquoi
il ne parle pas de crime parce qu'il y a
plusurs gens à faire pour l'instant je
veux dire faut déjà étayer le dossier il
y a des médecins légistes qui
travaillent il y a des photographies qui
sont prise c'est lourd c'est c'est un
gros dossier ça viendra en son temps ça
viendra en son temps mais je crois que
c'est indisp
c'est ça ça permettra aussi de de
définir les responsabilités alors le
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat Breno roto va déposer une
résolution sur ce sujet notamment pour
évoquer la qualification de crime contre
l'humanité j'imagine que les sénateurs
centriste vont soutenir cette résolution
quel va en être le message oui on a
parlé avec Bruno rutaillot et Gérard
Larché de cette résolution que nous
allons présenter ensemble et j'imagine
que elle sera signée par d'autres par
d'autres groupes au sein du du Sénat
j'espère le plus grand nombre en tous
les cas il faut être clair ça a été dit
par tous les orateurs à l'Assemblée
nationale comme au Sénat on a affaire à
des crimes de guerre vous venez de le
dire on a affaire à des scènes
absolument horribles euh et donc il y a
pas de de Wiet comme a dit le chef de
l'État il y a euh des choses qui doivent
être claires le Hamas c'est un groupe
terroristes ce sont pas des résistants
quand on est résistant on tire pas euh
dans une parti sur des jeunes euh on ne
décapite pas des bébés euh ça n'a rien à
voir ilentr pour mourir ils sont entrés
pour mourir ce ce sont des fanatiques
qui sont rentrés sur le territoire
israélien euh à la grande surprise du
monde qui pensaient que que Israël était
étit mieux armés pour pour sa défense et
ils sont venus pour mourir ceux qui ne
sont pas morts sont repartis avec des
otages alors est-ce que vous condamnez
néanmoins aussi la stratégie de ripost
de l'armée israélienne qui fait de
nombreuses victimes lors des
bombardements par exemple sur Gaza
écoutez chacun reconnaît le droit à à
Israël de se défendre peut pas imaginer
que Israël a rencontré la mort comme
comme ça a été le cas avec des femmes
des enfants des vieillards et et
qu'Israël comme certains le demandent et
notamment à l'extrême gauche disent on
va faire un cesser le feu c'est
impensable il faut que Israël puisse
défendre son peuple et à partir de là on
sait très bien qu'il va y avoir des des
postes très fortes qui ont déjà commencé
mais avec ces victimes civiles à Gaza
est-ce que malgré ce droit de se
défendre d'Israël est-ce qu'Israël ne
sort pas du droit international écoutez
c'est à Israël de mesurer sa riposte
mais on sait très bien et ça n'est pas
nouveau que le Hamas se sert des
habitants de Gaza comme d'un bouclier
humain ils servent d'otage
malheureusement c'est un des endroits du
monde qui est qui est le plus dense sur
cette petite bande de terre de 40
kilomètres il y a plus de 2 millions 2
millions et demi de d'habitants qui sont
entassés dans des conditions
épouvantables et ils sont pris en otage
par par le Hamas depuis déjà fort
longtemps alors c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ne faut pas euh supprimer
l'aide humanitaire qui peut exister en
direction de de ces populations car
l'Union européenne fournit l'aide
financière la plus importante à l'Union
européenne à l'Union à l'Autorité
palestinienne pardon certains estiment
qu'il faudrait couper néanmoins cette
aide parce qu'on dit qu'elle est
détournée facilement par le Hamas alors
vous vous dites quoi alors il y a
vraisemblablement et c'est pas nouveau
on en parle depuis longtemps une partie
de l'aide qui est détourné par le Hamas
mais il y a différents types d'aide il y
a l'aide humanitaire celle qui nécessite
qu'on discute des des couloir
humanitaire c'est-à-dire pour apporter
de l'eau de la nourriture des
médicaments ce qui est indispensable
pour la sur fait actuellement c'est en
discussion euh et puis il y a l'aide au
développement euh c'est cette aide là
qu'il faut mesurer en tous les cas il
faut peut-être suspendre en partie mais
il faut surtout mieux contrôler il faut
absolument que les
ONG proches des Palestiniens les les
associations spécialisées certaines
banques et puis le le transfert des
aides soit beaucoup mieux contrôler
c'est indispensable et c'est cette aide
làà l'aide humanitaire il faut on peut
pas là aussi en rajouter vis-à-vis des
populations de Gaza on peut pas les tuer
il faut il faut j'allais dire qu'elle
puisse survivre donc l'aide humanitaire
est indispensable alors on l'a vu au
Parlement français il y a une quasi
unanimité dans les réactions de soutien
à Israël de la part de tous les groupes
politiques même si le groupe la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale fait
preuve d'une certaine ambiguïté dans sa
position la présidente du groupe mathil
pano ne parle pas d'attaque terroriste
du Hamas mais de crime de guerre ça vous
choque cette ambiguïté bien sûr enfin je
veux dire tout toutes les forces
politiques françaises sont unanimes y
compris une grande partie des
socialistes et et des ver et des
communiste je pense que le LFI s'est
disqualifié et que LFI est sorti du
champ républicain je ne pas reconnaître
les horreurs du Hamas les qualifi de
résistant comment vous expliquez ce
refus ce refus de la France insoumise en
tout cas d'une majorité de de députés de
la France de de qualifier le ramass
d'organisation terroriste pourquoi oh je
pense pense que tout bonnement c'est un
calcul électoral de bas étage et je veux
pas en dire plus parce que ça ça serait
vraiment faire trop d'honneur à LFI qui
est lâché de toutes part je je pense que
quand même la politique a des règles et
que il y a au moins des règles
humanitaires et et d'humanité
élémentaire quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé on ne peut que reconnaître le
caractère terroriste et et abominable de
ce que fait le le Hamas ne pas le
reconnaître c'est aller contre une
évidence que le monde entier reconnaît
alors que faire face à cette position de
la France insoumis certains au sein de
la droite sénatoriale propose une
dissolution de ce mouvement de ce parti
quelle est quelle est votre position
écoutez il y a des règles de droit la
première en démocratie c'est l'élection
donc j'espère que les les Français et en
tous les cas les électeurs qui avaient
pu porter leur voix sur etfi tiendront
le plus grand compte du comportement de
de ces élus visiblement dans les son â
d'opinion on voit que 84 % des Français
condamn la position de de LFI puis la
seconde chose c'est qu'il y a des règles
de droit après s'il y a des plaintes
c'est à la justice de de les instruire
Elizabeth borne à ce sujet est allé
jusqu'à déplorer une forme
d'antisémitisme oui c'est pas mais ça
n'est pas nouveau là encore
souvenez-vous du comportement de madame
auonau qui recevait monsieur
Corbin des des propos qui ont été tenus
à différentes reprises par les membres
de LFI ils sont toujours sur le fil du
rasoir parce que il s'appuie sur un
électorat qu'ils essaient de flatter au
maximum et tout ça est assez répugnant
alors HERV Marseille ce conflit pose des
questions géopolitiques que faire face
au pays alliés du Hamas on va écouter
sur ce point Claude maluré votre
collègue président du groupe les
indépendants au Sénat la guerre est
revenue et nous ne voulons pas la voir
je ne parle pas seulement de la guerre
du Hamas contre Israël mais des guerres
et menaces au Moyen-Orient en Afrique en
mer de Chine et maintenant en Europe
c'est la guerre des dictatures contre
les démocraties elle est
mondiale les mains qui ont tranché la
gorge des enfants d'Israël venaient de
Gaza mais le cerveau est atééron des
mots très forts de la part de Claude
muret RV Marseille l'Iran est un soutien
connu du Hamas est-ce que les
occidentaux doivent prendre de nouvelles
sanctions face aux dirigeants
iraniens j'ai dénoncé cette situation au
Sénat à l'occasion des des questions
d'actualité en mettant en cause le Qatar
et l'Iran chacun sait que ils sont
proches du Hamas après il faut mesurer
leur implication il suffit pas de de
dénoncer les Américains ont commencé à
le faire avec un certain nombre de de
preuves il faudra aller jusqu'au bout
mais là où je crois qu'il y a
défaillance c'est au niveau de l'Europe
nous appartenons à une communauté qui
devrait être une communauté qui parle
d'une voix et qui soit forte comme on
l'a fait euh pour la Russie concernant
dossier ukrainien là il y a eu beaucoup
de confusion dans la réaction de de la
Communauté européenne on suspend des
aide non finalement on les suspend pas
euh on dénonce on dénonce pas je crois
qu'il faut que on arrête cette confusion
et que l'Europe parle d'une voix d'une
voix forte pour dénoncer ce qui doit
l'être et puis également pour relancer
le processus de paix parce que après la
guerre vient la paix et singulièrement
ça nous rappelle que il y a toujours le
dossier est palestinien vous vous y
croyez vraiment à une relance possible
au vu de des abominations commises de de
l'extrême gravité de la situation pour
est-ce que vous pensez que un jour à
moyen terme une une paix sera possible
et la estceon peut laisser les choses en
l'état on risque d'avoir dans 6 mois
dans un an dans 3 ans d'autres d'autres
massacres d'autres guerres regardez il y
a eu le processus des accords
d'Abraham une part de ce qu'a fait le
Hamas c'était pour donc on précise les
accords d'Abraham c'est le rapprochement
entre Israël et certains pays arabe
voilà et et ce qu'a fait le Hamas c'est
justement d'essayer de mettre un terme à
ces accords et donc ces accords tiennent
il suffit de voir la réaction de
l'Arabie Saoudite euh ou du Maroc bon
euh donc il est important d'accompagner
cette dynamique des accords d'Abraham et
de relancer parallèlement avec et avec
qui avec le successeur de du ramas avec
avec quel interlocuteur avec les pays de
la région avec les pays arabes qui sont
signataires des accords euh d'Abraham
puisque visiblement euh ces accords ont
l'air de bien tenir et donc il faut
relancer le processus de paix parce que
sinon on aura d'année en année de moin
en mois des événements comme ceux que
nous venons de vivre on peut pas faire
l'impasse on l'a fait c'est une erreur
on a cru qu'avec les accords d'Abraham
on écartait le problème palestinien on
en parlait plus il revient avec force
devant nous est-ce que vous reconnaissez
que dans ce processus de paix finalement
le Premier ministre israélien benamin
netanahou a aussi une responsabilité
finalement dans l'échec de la paix avec
par exemple la poursuite de la
colonisation je crois que collectivement
que ce soit les Américains les
gouvernements israéliens nous-mêmes nous
avons été trop absent du du dossier
palestinien en pensant qu'il ne se
passait plus rien et que il fallait les
Ch laisser les choses en l'état il vient
à nouveau il est il se convoque devant
nous avec l'horreur que nous observons
et donc il faut bien sûr euh régler la
situation euh actuelle euh israël va
j'imagine de plus en plus monter en
puissance pour régler le problème
militaire mais parallèlement il faut que
la diplomatie et singulièrement la
France agissent en Europe pour relancer
le processus de paix et pour accompagner
la dynamique euh des accords d'Abraham
merci HERV marcer pour cet éclairage sur
la situation au Proche Orient on va
revenir à l'actualité nationale puisque
les députés ont entamé l'examen du
budget 2024 cela s'annonce difficile
pour le gouvernement qui n'a qu'une
majorité relative on le sait en
commission des finances lors de l'examen
des recettes les députés ont par exemple
voté le rétablissement de l'exit taxe
contre la volonté du gouvernement les
points chauds de ce budget avec els
mondingava sur le papier le gouvernement
affiché deux objectifs sortir
progressivement du quoi qu'il en coûte
et garder des mécanismes de protection
contre
l'inflation tout en respectant sa
doctrine en matière budgétaire ni dette
ni taxes supplémentaires l'argent
gratuit c'est fini et c'est fini pour
longtemps donc il serait totalement
irresponsable de poursuivre les dépenses
au même rythme au moment où les taux
d'intérêt ont atteint les 4 % et
alourdissent la charge de la dette qui
s'élèvera je le rappel à 74 milliards
d'euros en
2027 mais dès la commission difficile
pour la majorité relative de tenir ses
ambitions le gouvernement enchaîne les
revers le président de la commission des
finances ériic coocrel a fait adopter un
amendement pour taxer les super
dividendes je vous incite à réfléchir au
message qu'on envoie on peut demander
des efforts aux gens mais à ce momentl
faut le demander à tout le monde et là
notamment on touche pas des gens qui
j'allais dire ù la la quelqu
augmentation qui va leur être fait
déstabiliser leur fortune amendement
voté grâce au voix de la gauche mais
aussi du MoDem qui avait électriser les
débats l'an dernier avec une disposition
similaire car le gouvernement est aussi
défié par sa propre majorité le modem
donc se montre très attaché à des
mesures de justice fiscale quand le
groupe horizon souhaite lui accélérer
les baisses d'impôts les débats dans
l'hémicycle commencent mardi après-midi
ils finiront inévitablement par un 493
reste à savoir quand Hervé Marseille
l'argent gratuit c'est fini nous dit
Bruno Le Maire qui prévoit des de
l'ordre de 16 milliards d'euros avec ce
budget est-ce que c'est assez pour vous
euh pas vraiment parce que là-dedans il
y a la fin des dispositif
exceptionnel concernant l'énergie en
particulier donc peut mieux faire tarif
oui peut mieux faire vous savez c'est
pas une affaire nouvelle on a 3
milliards de dettes 150 milliards de
déficit annuel c'est pas rien avec des
taux d'intérêt qui augmentent François
Fillon déjà disait je suis à la tête
d'un État en faillite il y a pas si
longtemps que ça et là vous dites quoi
vous alors Bro le disait je suis à
l'euro prè ça c'est pas vraiment vu donc
il est temps de commencer à faire des
économies parce que ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça oui mais où vous les
voyez où ces économies économ on va
parler des des recettes mais d'abord
quelle dépenses on peut réduire ah bah
il faut rabter un tas de dépenses il y a
un tas d'agences par exemple qui existe
dont on se demande à quoi elle
sertc il faut les économies c'est euh
plein plein d'économies partout je veux
dire c'est une addition donc il faut s'y
mettre il faut une volonté politique
déjà pour aller vers ça et il faut à la
fois des économies et le levier fiscal
alors les économies d'un côté mais
trouver des recettes aussi justement on
va parler des recettes on a vu les
députés de la commission des finances
qui ont adopté avec une alliance entre
la gauche et le modem et bien une taxe
sur les super dividendes vous RV
Marseille et les sénateurs centristes
demandent une taxe sur les super profits
vous êtes confiants vous vous pensez
qu'une telle mesure peut être adoptée
dans ce budget euh oui et non je vais
m'expliquer on parle j'entends que les
amis du du groupe horizon veulent
davantage
d'économie oui mais on a on a déjà
supprimé plein d'impôts la taxe
d'habitation la redevance
[Musique]
télévision et cetera et cetera 35
milliards donc il faut des nouvelles r
fiscal compensé par quoi bon et je suis
pas totalement sûr que les gens se soni
aperçus qu'on avait supprimé la taxe
d'hab tion ou l'evance télé donc le
bénéfice politique me paraît discutable
bon il faut trouver des nouvelles
recettes d'abord il y a un problème
social on est dans un pays où il y a 9
millions dit-on de gens qui sont en
situation de précarité dont certains ont
du mal à se nourrir tous les jours
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à avoir des
dividendes insolents d'un certain nombre
de grandes entreprises qui distribuent
des des dividendes absolument faramineux
il y a un problème d'exemplarité je
pense que l'angle social est un angle
mort de la politique gouvernementale
depuis déjà plusieurs années il y a des
actions qui sont positives on le voit
bien en direction de l'emploi il ne veut
pas entendre il ne veut pas entendre vos
arguments puis qu'il y a toujours pas de
taxes sur les superdivid qu'elle a des
chances ou mais je suis ravi que mes
amis du MoDem pu avec d'autres avec le
soutien d'Éric cocrel ah bah tout tous
les renforts sont bienvenus pour la
bonne cause et
donc je je dis que c'est une bonne chose
mais en même temps je suis pas sûr que
ça aille jusqu'au bout parce que si'il y
a 493 le gouvernement va sortir ça du
texte qu'il présentera donc c'est pour
ça que je vous dis oui ça a été voté oui
ça risque d'être dans le texte mais
peut-être et vraisemblablement si à 493
le gouvernement le sortira et je trouve
que c'est dommage parce qu'il y a un
problème d'exemplarité sociale ça sert à
montrer aux gens quand même qu'on prend
au plus riche et puis il faut
augmenter j'allais dire les barêes de la
flat taxe qui sont payé en particulier
là aussi la flat la taxe c'est c'est un
un prélèvement forfaitaire unique c'est
le pfu sur les sociétés sur les sociétés
qui distribu alors en parlant de taxes
les députés on l'a vu ont voté cette
taxe mise en place sous Nicolas Sarkozi
l'exit taxe pour pénaliser les
actionnaires qui transfèrent leur
domicile fiscal hors de France pour
échapper à l'impôt est-ce que vous
trouvez que ça pourrait être une bonne
mesure oui c'est une bonne mesure moi je
je soutiens cette cette mesure elle est
modulable d'année en année en fonction
du j'allais dire de la situation
générale et puis il y a les les les
tranches du barê de l'imposition qui
peuvent être modulé les plus basses
évidemment doivent tenir compte de
l'inflation mais les plus hautes sont
pas nécessairement indexables donc il y
a tout un tas de leviers fiscaux qui
permettent de retrouver des marges de
recettes pour conclure un dernier mot RV
Marseille sur ce 493 le gouvernement l'a
annoncé il va utiliser le 493 pour
passer en force le budget à l'Assemblée
finalement à quoi ça sert de débattre et
de faire des amendements sur ce budget
bah écoutez c'est c'est nos institutions
le Parlement est fait pour débattre et
donc nous débattons nous votons le
gouvernement utilise les armes qui sont
à sa disposition merci ce sera donc le
mot de la fin Hervé Marseille merci
d'avoir été l'invité de cette
[Musique]
émission